all right
let's kick this baby off
um did you have a good Keynote
good to be here in person in real life
and then you're locked down here has
been worse than ours in Sydney but uh it
was uh
uh bad for us so even worse for you guys
eh I love the keynote myself
um the Highlight seeing friends and uh
learning what AI was what was it a
collaborative
encompassing term for stuff that isn't
really working right
okay I thought that was quite good and I
love this demo
all right so uh good to see Melbourne
very beautiful last time I was here
didn't see this beautiful building
a 108. it really stands out should be
famous
so we saw the booth last night getting
put together that was great we have the
ssw TV guys around recording and we went
out had a bit of fun in the city it's
been awesome
uh there's a lot of QR codes in
Melbourne a lot more than uh we have up
in Sydney you sick of them
yes all right
awesome so uh the TV guys are here if
you have if you want to uh have a little
uh five minute uh recording with them of
some tip you have sing out and I'll do
that for you
all right so today's session we're going
to be talking about 10 tips to rocking
as an Azure architect uh a lot of us are
doing Cloud all the time
but there is like a number of things
that I often talk to with the ssw devs
about the next steps what you should be
doing so I'm just going to be going
through some of those tips all right
so I want to talk about the architecture
Center I want to talk about uh saving
dollars when you're dealing with Azure
usually comes from the early
conversations automating stuff is part
of your job to be coaching others and a
whole lot of other rules about Azure
this is me I'm the Chief Architect at
ssw I'm a Microsoft Regional director
and I'm a scrum master
and we have a new office I thought I'd
tell you we have Sydney Milton Brisbane
we now have Newcastle all up in
Ukrainian lights very nice
all right
and we have also done a Rebrand from
that to that we went dark mode
there's a lot of arguments over that one
but we did it
all right if you want to uh win some
prizes over at the booth you can scan
this QR code earn some points on the app
do some other crazy things throw some
things get a tattoo earn some points and
uh there's lots of things I want a few
bands myself
um so have some fun all right one more
QR code
can you everyone scan this please this
is going to be part of the session
you're going to be answering some
questions
all right
this is my first experience in China
because in China everything many years
ago was QR code based before we got
before we got covered we probably
wouldn't be using QR codes but they were
using it for everything with WeChat
all right so here's the first question
do you primarily regard yourself already
as a cloud architect or would you say
you're a developer on cloud
or a developer mainly on-prem mainly we
all do lots of things or your technical
your technical but not a developer
or if you're none of those
all right
so you'll see uh we are primarily at
this point in time
mostly developers doing Cloud stuff okay
there we go
all right keep on going so the next
question I have for you
is how many years have you been doing
Azure are you a newbie on your first
year
been doing it up to five years or up to
10 years
or are you really old like you know
Andrew coats when did you start using
azure
2008 all right that was before I was
born but that was
a long long time ago in fact does anyone
actually remember the term Red Dog
oh only two really oldies okay that was
before azure
and uh good um I I just put this other
question in here about AWS and gcp just
to check we had no spies in the room
okay that's good
um look Azure is a beast there's a lot
of services there there's hundreds of
services it's in fact hard to keep track
of how much is in there
ah
there's essentially 200 really fantastic
important services but when it all comes
down to like 80 percent of it is in the
you know the top 10 or 15 services so
there is a session that we do and it's
actually online you can watch it it's
where I go through the top nine Services
of azure
it's called the nine nights of azure we
also have a day where we go through this
on Azure superpowers it's a it's a
couple hundred dollars for the day uh
there's a few of the cloud Architects
that do that at ssw and it's a good day
so basically we just go through uh the
Computing Services data services
security stuff logic apps Bots and
containers all right
so I would like to ask you how many
people here have actually used the Azure
architecture Center
all right so open your app this is not
interactive we don't put our hands
anymore that's old school
okay we open up our app and we look at
the screen
and uh
oh look at this all right well this is
definitely worth talking now
Okay because I'm going to skip over this
because everybody had already used it
great
so
I'll just I'll wait for a couple more
answers
all right
okay all right so most of you have not
heard of it well it's already worth
coming to the session then if that's the
case
so you are sitting down you've talked to
the customer about the new
um requirements how you're going to do
this you spec out what's going to be
done now most people will do a document
or some type of long email or whatever's
going on documenting what's going on in
our company in that meeting we always
include a diagram okay because pictures
are worth a thousand words as you would
know and uh
you know to make your own diagram we
have this rule here you can have a look
at it but it's how to make your own
diagram all right now uh it's basically
you think ahead what you're going to be
using
and then you will do a bit of a a graph
or diagram like this you draw i o is
kind of the best one out there
and we have one of these for every
single solution we have now uh to get
going on that because many of these are
complicated you're trying to work things
out you might not know what to do okay
but Microsoft have this Azure
architecture Center and I'll just
quickly show you this but if you jump
into here
and you browse the Azure Arc browse
azure architectures
you can come in here and we'll search
for we'll search for health in this case
all right so let's just say we're doing
a Health Solution you could come in here
and look here and be reading the common
Services you could be using how you
could set this up if it's just an hour
meeting you might want to say all right
so I broadly understand what we should
do for the next meeting you could take
this but most of the time you're
spending some days kind of flashing this
out and this is where you might start so
you might start add one of these
diagrams go to draw.io draw dot IO
follow some of these patterns and start
putting in the specific customer
requirements for that
all right so uh whoops
I will just uh also just go back because
that Azure architecture Center
is pretty awesome
there's a lot of stuff on here so I'll
just go back one more step here
there's a bunch of stuff here so you can
look through here and this site is
should be your first stop you come in
here you can see designing for the cloud
optimizing your workload choosing the
right Tech
a whole bunch of scenarios so for
example if your customer says or I'm
really worried about
um we've had a lot of load problems in
the past at nine o'clock in the morning
every kid from the schools all logs on
at that time uh how are you going to
handle that well there's you don't need
to invent anything all this has all been
done it's just about knowing what to do
you could come down here to say
application design patterns
uh you can look through learn a whole
lot of patterns this is obviously if you
know the right one you go to it and you
read about it if you don't know you kind
of try to work it out we're going to be
using cqrs in this solution we're using
event sourcing
we'll be using uh
query based load leveling okay that
sounds close
we'll come in here
and we'll read about the problem seeing
if this is close to what the customer is
asking for
you'll see a little diagram here you
could take it as is or modify it we've
got our task they're going through the
message to the service look closely at
the little diagrams underneath where it
says requests received at a variable
rate see how is that what they're
describing that they come in like this
but we want it smoothed out messages
processed at a more consistent rate
there is a mass of content on here
nicely well organized and you end up
being pointed to the right bits in
docs.microsoft so I think that you
should like that
all right so let's um go back
uh hopefully you can see that the
architecture Center is bloody important
it comes with uh lots of diagrams and a
variety of scenarios it does not include
your arm Jason or your arm bicep
hopefully Microsoft will include that
one day because that'll take us to the
next step
um
uh it has all those Cloud patterns that
I just described and you can learn more
about it on that rule if you want it
all right let's talk about the next one
bicep have you used bicep before
open that phone tell us if you think
it's awesome because you have or that
you have looked at it but you prefer one
of the other Solutions
you've looked at it but you're not
interested
or you haven't heard of it
okay all right so there's plenty of
people
have not heard of it which is good and
there's plenty of people that have heard
of it and are already interested in it
via the description
all right
so this infrastructure is code really
really important
um
we have a rule on this
I actually have nothing to do on the
weekend so I just write rules
and
this is the common
problem you start looking at what you
need to do in Azure and this is normal
you start clicking through working out
um uh basically they refer to this going
through as exploring or click Ops you
know
so we are just creating all the
resources manually what you can do from
that point you you should not pass go
from that point you should open it up
and save that
um
Json into a folder uh now those
templates are very verbose they will get
you up and running but they are not good
at making changes quickly beyond that
all right you can
um
but there's a better way all right so
what you can do is author your own arm
templates
you can author your own arm template
save it in a folder do it like that
or you can use a tool like Pharma okay
and Pharma is an F-sharp tool it's a lot
more readable but there is a better tool
than that and that is bicep okay so
bicep is what we recommend it's what we
use on our projects it's free so that's
good
um it's got It's a really nice way of
basically describing out your your Azure
application and having all those
resources created for you for you now
be aware there are other ones like
palumi anyone using plumy
no one okay that is also a popular one
and terraform
any terraform guys oh way more so it's
like quarter of the room okay
and how many people
um are using
um bicep or planning to use bicep
okay so it's about the same all right
cool yes now terraform is uh also
awesome so if you've got terraform
that's good it is more pricey because
it's not free but it is goes across
Cloud so if you're going to switch to
Cloud there might be a good reason to
use it all right
all right
so you can grab that bicep extension it
is certainly whatever solution you
choose it's going to be better than the
arm Jason now all these bicep files are
kind of like modules and they can you
can chain them together you can link
them I have I'll just show you a little
example
so this is an example from William
Lemberg he did a talk at NDC Sydney you
can watch the whole thing just on bicep
the whole time but he put up all his
code here if you go into demos
and we'll go into registries
and what has he got here he's got the
full stack web app so he's put the
entire web app there but the guts of it
is how he's
um put his infrastructure's code so he's
put each one separately so he's made his
key Vault bicep file there he's got his
SQL database as a separate file he's got
his storage and web app so they're all
separate now if we were to look in we'll
look in the key Vault file
um here he comes through he you know he
sets up his key Vault here he defines it
all and he's good to go all right so
that is the better way of doing it
completely reproducible and if we go
into uh say the the main guy that calls
all the other ones here this full stack
web app.bicep
if we look in here we should be able to
find oh there there is and where's his
key vault
here here we go
okay
so uh there's his reference to calling
that and that's so you can just chain
them together it's quite a nice way of
modulizing that together all right
so now if you think about when you're
doing a net code and you've got
um you get
you know you can just instantiate a new
get package you don't have to actually
know the phone location all the same
same thing here you know his bicep
resources there and he's calling it okay
so oh all all pretty nice I think you'll
be impressed when you use bicep it works
well
all right let's talk about the next one
the next one is Bill shock has anyone
here
experience an unexpected bill in the
cloud before
the reasons might be yes I was not
monitoring my costs
or
um
yes the resources being used were more
expected than I had expected they were
or three yes I've been hit by a denial
of wallet attack
which is when a rogue actor decides that
they will attack a company they don't
like and uh
basically use their resources making
their bill go up without their sales
going up we don't mind if our bill our
Cloud bills go up if we see a spike in
invoices and sales that's great but not
without it or my favorite one which I
hear from a lot of customers yes someone
added an extra resource without getting
approval
Rogue Developers
who's experienced that
now who has been that developer that did
it and got in trouble there he is
what's your name sir
cannot mean to tell me don't worry all
right all right let's um let's talk
about this monthly spend
so this monthly spend so you've got a
web app database reports you know it
usually starts with you start using
services and you worry about the bill
later
so it's often about not planning ahead
now how many people here have used the
Azure calculator before
oh that is awesome okay so I reckon
we've got 70 of the room using that um
Azure calculator
and I am going to uh just go through it
and kind of go through some of the
thinking that goes on
so you've got you've got all your
resources that you can pick from and go
shopping essentially
uh and down here
I don't know why they've got this is
called like I think it's called a
skeleton layout but it's meant to do
this while it's loading so I'm just
going to hang here and wait for it to
load but it never will
so let's ignore that UI let's pretend
that we're having a conversation we're
saying all right so how should we do
this new one we all do it the
conventional way we're going to use an
app service and a SQL database and get
this thing done and dusted
all right I guess we could do a static
site with something else but I think
let's go with what we know so we'll go
with an app service we'll click that
what happened
oh scroll down it's down here they need
a little animation don't they
so we come down here and it's 54 bucks a
month whoops it's in West us
I have chosen Australia 1 000 times and
Azure has never remembered that I want
Australia now I want Melbourne Southeast
and it's 70 bucks
that's reasonable isn't it we'll get
approval for that whoops no we don't
want to choose windows we want it to be
cheaper which is Linux
70 bucks too
13 bucks that's much more reasonable wow
um but we better not deploy on basic I
don't think do you think
what do you think if we Deploy on basic
we won't get lots of benefits like Auto
scale blah blah blah so you don't want
to do that we want to pay
we'll go standard so we'll go from 13
bucks to 90 bucks
oh well we need that
oh you really shouldn't deploy live
production two Giga Ram you need at
least four right like at least
so I think we better go to four Giga RAM
and that will be
from 90 bucks to 170 bucks
it's getting more expensive
um you know they should have here
because you think you've gone to a much
better machine but it should have a
warning here warning your own old
spindle discs you need ssds
so you if they put that there they'll
sell more
but so if you want that you go from
standard to premium V2
and we're going to go from 175 bucks oh
if you get cheaper for going better
give me an analogy for that I don't even
have one all right so we just got thrown
in ssds
I wish my wife could find go shopping as
efficiently as I go shopping all right I
just got better for cheaper
all right so 90 bucks pretty good
all right so
what else
uh you know you could go up to
um
V3 which would give me more than four
Giga Ram
what's it going to go from 90 bucks to
oh 130 you reckon you can get approval
for that's not too much more it's a lot
better but you want to know what you
should be doing always having the
conversation
can how many years are we going to
commit to this app
oh I'm not really sure well but we can
commit to a year can't we oh definitely
for a year all right so let's go there
and commit to a year
and we're down to 80 bucks right so
they're kind of the the the the the
common conversations you would have you
now have a beefy instance
uh and it's cheap
great awesome I'm very happy with that
oh it's actually only the app service we
need a database
so we'll go and choose SQL
what happened oh that's right I go down
here
so we have our app service for 85 bucks
look at that SQL Server oh that's right
I have to tell Microsoft that I would
like to be in Melbourne
imagine adding up the hourly rate of
every developer in Australia for this
one
oh okay
now what's going on
oops sixteen hundred dollars this app is
not feasible we'll have to park this one
oh I just realized
the core okay we don't need dedicated
instance we'll use what we use right
data transaction unit for SQL
oh that's much better
much much much better
okay now uh we will need to so five
bucks for the database is pretty good
deal we should go standard because we're
going to deploy this for real
and there we are so 20 bucks if we look
at this we have just
oh look around hundred dollars it even
sounds nice tell the boss so that that
is kind of going through oh but of
course when you do this type of stuff
you should go
um conventional mainstream app
mainstream
app service
and there we are good to go all right
now now you should do your comparison
and we're going to do our comparison
let's do it like with a modern site
we'll uh if almost all the recent sites
we've done have been our static sites
this
site Let's uh assume that it's not
relational we could use Cosmos if we
wanted to there's a good reason to use
Cosmos because you got you know Planet
scale we will go
uh static let's have a look
stag web apps who's used static web apps
okay all right less than 20 of you um it
is definitely the way to go
stag web apps uh we can't re we
shouldn't well we could go on free it's
cheap but you you you need auth and you
need you know durable functions most
most solutions so you're going to go
with standard and it goes to nine bucks
nine bucks all right
um
that would get you a couple of coffees
in Sydney
okay
all right so that's pretty good
um that is that all I've got to do oh
that's all I've got to do great
all right let's
what else that's it I will need a
database so let's get rid of this and
let's come in here and go to Azure
Cosmos
oh go down
and here we go Azure Cosmos pay as you
go 23 bucks
wow and that's all I really have to do
this this is a lot easier choosing all
this stuff and I'm just going to put in
here
cool static web app compare whether I
want to go like I didn't have to select
where I was and all those things because
um you know stay it has front door it
caches it everywhere this is going to be
blazingly fast and cheaper so why
wouldn't you choose it
all right all cool
Grace so you start off your project and
you look at the cost and you give them
those costs and you give them a
comparison give them the choice of A and
B
um but you can see the modern services
are nicer to use so I did this before
about a month or so ago and look at the
prices they were 146 versus 50. so you
can see that they've got the prices are
actually coming down
okay the only thing in covert that's
coming down
so I went from 146 to 100 because I just
did it with you and uh was it 20
something it was 50. okay so just just
delay your Azure decisions
and eventually you'll come down to
basically nothing
all right
now the major tip is make your customers
make that decision because if you don't
you're wasting money lots of money
all right and now look I did give you a
contrived example a more realistic you
know Enterprise data warehouse example
might have synapse in it and analytics
services and power bi and better than
stuff in Europe for a couple of grand
per month Etc depending on the size of
your your organization what you need
all right now the next thing is
monitoring your dollars okay monitoring
those dollars and devs and Architects
aren't that good at this where do you go
you go into cost management you click on
cost analysis and you see how that bill
is growing and you check that that's
growing with usage versus sales versus
everything else so that is an app
growing uh it's a real example but I
want you to understand about burning
dollars burning dollars is dangerous so
on the left hand side you choose budgets
and the way that I usually tell people
to to go through is add the budgets so
for example
uh it is always at some of the parts you
should have budgets per application in
your company or per Department in your
company how you ever slice it but then
you have an overall one as well so an
overall one which is groups or more
um
now when you hit those Milestones or
those limits
it won't turn off
okay it's gonna run away so uh you would
you got to be monitoring those alerts
and so it's all well and good to set up
a budget but you've got to set up your
alerts okay so you set up your budget
and then you come in here and you set up
your alerts on the left hand side you
click on cost alerts and you set that up
all right
alrighty
so let's move on to number four
and this is a common problem in large
organizations that have on-prem they
will discuss using some of azure
but they don't really want to because
that's additional monthly cost
because if we put it on our on-premise
stuff that's not going to cost us
anything
right
you have these conversations
okay now I was really happy when this
little tool came out from Microsoft
because it's hard to tell them the cost
I had this experience where we got rid
of one of the Sands in ssw and I didn't
understand how massively the air
conditioner bill would come down you
know um so it was costing us nearly a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
we're a small company with the body air
conditioner
so what's the cost most people don't
know and you come in here
and they have this beautiful calculator
here
for your company so there is you have
um you tell them what workloads what
servers you have what operating systems
how big is the CPU what databases blah
blah blah there's a lot and it will it
once you tell it the story of your
on-premise workloads
you will get a cost and it's pretty
pretty good I haven't had customers be
able to dispute it
okay and it's it's
um it you know Azure takes fairly uh
conservative estimates with this so I
put through here an example of a
um a couple of customers Blended
together okay with it Departments of
about 20 and uh you know substantial
businesses but you go through you enter
their their service
you enter their databases
their storage you come through adjust
any assumptions if you want to because
they've got Windows assurance and stuff
like that SQL Server software Assurance
you come through enter the um well it's
already set up for you with um the
electricity cost the storage cost the it
labor costs look at the bottom here like
hourly rate for it administrator 32 an
hour
okay
more than conservative right
and that was a million dollars for their
setup
and they said surely that's not right
and then they came back and they
couldn't dispute any of that and it was
probably in the ballpark okay so this is
helpful if you have that problem
um yeah your on-premise stuff I know
it's a sunk cost but it's a real cost
and it's continuing and continuing and
continuing you need to get off that so
that is the difference just
um graphically that is that cost and
that is the same services
on clad now that strucks you as way
different because Cloud can be expensive
too right
um but in some big companies cloud is
crazy cheap like they're nuts to be
wasting this much money every year
you're in this
specific example which is real real
world is 1.1 million and sixty thousand
dollars
if they now of course they've got to pay
for a lot of software to be fixed up and
deployed and stuff but it's um uh it's
where they should go very quickly
and here's the breakdown so that that
site gives you a breakdown of
graphically of all the different costs
on premise versus what the costs are
going to be in the cloud
okay and
um for the accountants there you go and
yeah they it's definitely something you
should be doing
let's talk about learning
okay
do we need to um do we need much more
than docs.mic stuff that is uh an
incredibly successful site okay it's
they've done a magical job with
docs.microsoft
um now the problem with docs.microsoft
is this
just like JavaScript the definitive
guide and the other book JavaScript the
good parts
you only really want the good parts
right
it's too much stuff
so how many people have read the Azure
developers guide
140 pages
okay give this man a star okay I'll get
you I'll get you a free tattoo in the
booth
all right so let's um
come in here I'm just going to click on
this
and uh this is a PDF Microsoft make it
every year
uh
PDFs aren't they old school
okay now uh it goes through everything
and this is a good way to get familiar
with all the lingo
um it goes to power-ups
Andrew Coast this would be your favorite
bit
yeah you're already it's all right so
you click on and of course they all
point off to Microsoft Docs
not all of them but yes there we go so
the bits and pieces now I've just gone
to one random bit but that these this is
a substantial document it's good to
flick through get a bit of a handle on
this
um it's it's a monster 140 pages but
it's it's not as bad as you think it is
now
this thing
um is refreshed every year it mainly
covers building Cloud native apps uh
with visual studio and Azure devops and
GitHub right they're the the guts of
what we need to know and it it links off
to there's a lot more stuff
um than that but that's that's the guts
of it now
not everybody learns by reading a a PDF
right so you've got um work out what
your budget is but
most people are either deciding
depending on whether the company's
paying or they're paying or whatever
um you know 35 bucks a month
um so I'll talk in the annual amounts
500 bucks a year or 100 bucks a year or
they just don't want to spend anything
on this what are your choices you got
pluralsight which is now lecture based
and then they have a tutorial right
and you've got LinkedIn learning you got
udemy and you got YouTube Good Old
YouTube has everything anyway all right
so but
there is one problem with all of this
you need to have your Azure instance I'm
going to call it bring your own azure
okay is that a term
okay I just invented it all right so
bring your own Azure so you have to have
that story sorted out
or you can use Microsoft learn
who's already using Microsoft learn
oh a third of you okay that's very sad
uh Microsoft learned Microsoft has spent
a fortune in this and when you go
through this
um it automatically gives you an Azure
instance for say a day it does die off
but you get that instance that you can
Muck around do your tutorial it's
everything you want Microsoft should
charge for this
like this is worth serious uh dollars
out of a training budget they don't
because they want to get you
um educated on Azure okay so they give
it to you and you're crazy not to use it
okay this is a great way of learning so
make sure this is what you're you're
getting your developers to be using
so once you've got them a bit educated
you now need to work with your
developers to make sure the next step is
automation so we go from education to
automation there's plenty of stuff on
Microsoft learn as well
but you want to be looking out for click
Ops okay
you want to be looking out when you see
them do stuff like you know go the Azure
portal
Resource Group app service advanced
tools browsing to WWE root drag and
dropping artifacts you know Windows
Explorer or um finder oh gosh I have to
now cater for Apple
yes my goodness I got problems in too
many of our developers are choosing
these new Macs with M1 chips giving our
assist admins headaches
oh my goodness
anyway that's click Ops
so what you want to do is go and help
them give them a little bit of love get
them to install the vs code Azure
extension pack
okay who's already done this step
two people what okay so once you've done
this and they're in vs code
you can organize your work in in this
case here's an example app service
functions resource groups so much nicer
make your changes and deploy all within
the one environment
so this is great it's great for pocs
it's just an extension right click
deploy grab that little nugget it's
awesome they're coding and deploying
from the same place they will they will
thank you for it so then you make your
change you deploy to your app service or
your function or your stake web app
whatever warning
this is for quick proof of concept
situations this is not long term of
course you should be getting them set up
with nice pipelines with Azure devops or
GitHub actions
um
that is what you do once it's really in
production
or before it gets to production okay but
that's very handy
and don't forget same story you've got
Visual Studio you've got these the cloud
Explorer it's similar
now I want to talk to you about the
azure tips and tricks site anyone
already know the site
one okay well this is useful okay so
we'll click on this
once you've looked through this I think
you'll be
um you'll be liking what's here
basically it's a Microsoft employee that
started and he wrote about uh 50 rules
well I shouldn't call them rules but
they're kind of like our rules 50 tips
50 tips and tricks
I think he should have simplified this
Azure tips would have been better
and so he's got lots of them you can see
we're up to 371 there's a bunch of
people now contributing
um they're they're all good
um I would come in here I will search
scale so you come here and you can what
do I how to run jobs at scale no I just
want to how to automatically scale Azure
app services oh that looks helpful I
will jump into there what have I got
okay how to automatically Scale app
Services the elastic Cloud where I need
scaling all right so I come down here
then now I click on this one okay
then I click on or Custom Auto scale so
they all are in this you know
step-by-step way what to do what to look
at what to do what to look at it's
really useful
and there's obviously
um hundreds in fact 300 of them
and if we want to look at the containers
here
okay we can click on containers we've
got lots and lots of stuff here about
containers so that's all good so you can
find lots of it's all nicely categorized
or we can go to
George
our
uh our
Melbourne with a Brazilian accent
um he is uh the Microsoft cloud advocate
all questions to do with uh kubernetes
or container apps you're the man are you
he answers every question for free
all right so there you go get his mobile
number and just arrest him that's his
job all right okay and all things open
source right
yep
there we go all right
so
um
so uh number nine we had enough
you want a couple more two more okay
more
okay this is probably the most important
one of all
you've got a site and you've deployed it
and you aren't casing it you got you're
not an architect you got your your site
isn't as fast it should be so you should
be using Azure front door
it is the most modern CDN in the world
it gives you global scale it's got
built-in thread detection
or you could use cloudflare which went
down yesterday
oh sorry I didn't mention that okay all
right
okay who's using cloudflare
three of you all right now were you
three commit to switching to front door
no okay all right no worries okay so I'm
going to give you another tip I think
this is kind of the only tip you really
need to run away with if you want to
make your projects better so you know
you have your projects you want to make
a project run smoothly
you get a scrum Master right
you break your work down you get a solid
hardcore scrum Master beats up the
product owner which causes most of the
problems usually and you have nice
performing Sprints you're getting stuff
done
yes who's doing scrum
all right everyone who's not doing scrum
oh who you work for the ATO
almost
okay now you get onto scrum but when you
have a team even a little baby team with
just a couple what the hell
um
broken link
I'm going to blame cloudflare
okay
there we go I'm a fixer I fix things all
right so we've got a video here um
William Lemberg does a bit of a talk
about why you need a cloud architect on
your on your team even if it's small so
let's just imagine you got you know a
couple of great depths you've got a
solution architect and a software
developer and a team you've got no Cloud
architect you really want to bump up
that team just like you'd bump up a team
with a scrum Master you want to have a
couple of strong devs with a cloud
architect
even if you can only have that cloud
architect on the team one day a week or
one day a fortnight or one day a month
whatever you can do you have to allocate
a cloud architect you that person should
then be in charge of load load testing
spend Ops which is you know the always
looking at the costs and the security if
you don't and you say who's in charge of
the cloud stuff they say oh we all are
which basically means no one you know
when everyone's in charge of something
no one's in charge of anything so make
sure that cloud architect is there so
that you know the the changes are being
made the right Tech is being used devops
is being done correctly they've got a
good data story
um all about the compute model and of
course that load testing before the
customer's load test for you
all right I've got a couple of bonus
ones
which is checking the latency
um between data centers this is a a nice
site that you can do just to quickly
check the latency between data centers
which is uh handy there is also another
site here which is more more advanced
it's got every
setting Under the Sun you can try
everything it's got some ads should
annoy me anyway
um but yes these are substantially good
sites that you can use to help you do
that
and the other one I'm going to mention
to you is the Azure update site the
services you cannot keep up with you
don't know where they're at but this
site is awesome so you can come through
here and you know you could look I know
you could go Cosmos
and uh you've got all these Services you
could say uh what's what's in preview or
I only want to see what is now available
I'm not interested in the stuff that's
in preview and you can click that and
it'll filter down etc etc so this is a
helpful site
all right so
uh you can scan this QR code and you'll
get points because you've now watched
the talk so you get I think you get a
few hundred points so scan that
with our great new app
let's have a look
um most people I'm just looking at the
summary of the um of the results most
people are Developers I think you can
all change your title to Cloud architect
now
on LinkedIn you can put me as a
reference nobody ever checks them anyway
okay
um
one to five years experience all right
so this has probably added another 10
years of experience onto that
Azure architecture Center well you've
all heard of this now so there you go
add that on as well
use that and that's wonderful
and uh
so most of you had not heard of bicep
you have now that's awesome
and oh look at this you weren't
monitoring your cross before
now go back make sure you have a budget
and make sure you have alerts there's no
forgiving for that and uh I had one of
our devs uh well I'm sure it's happened
to everyone I decide to test some a
whole lot of instances and left it on
for the weekend and now we're down a few
thousand dollars so it's fantastic
um
so hopefully
um you've learned a few bits and pieces
here
um we went through the uh architecture
Center we went through some devops
topics we talked about
um dollars we talked about performance
um and what else education lots of cool
stuff so hopefully that was useful now I
want you to know that I have all these
rules on rules to better Azure so I have
heaps and heaps and heaps of rules here
these are kind of the things that we go
through a lot in our company with the
devs
um yeah there's a lot of stuff which
exams are important
um
the nine important parts of azure blah
blah blah blah there's a lot and if you
come up to ssw rules here there's 2 700
of them that
that I I I now have a problem I think
that's starting to get a bit much you
can see the most recent and ones that
have been changed you can make a pull
request yourself
instead of emailing me or tweeting me
you just go in these are all we move
them all over to GitHub so for example
here is a rule
click on edit jump over to GitHub make
your pull request make your change and
we'll accept it if it's good
and uh there you go you'll be
contributing to the community we're all
learning and all getting better like
that look at that beautiful editor look
out good it's even better than Microsoft
docs Mr Coast don't you think
I think I think that was a yes I'm gonna
close it okay all right thank you very
much
[Applause]
others questions oh wow this gets better
and how do I get to the questions
uh
let's see
uh what's that thing called slido
slider who was it
comparative
ly all right peers read me one
Microsoft learn has a lot of
certifications attached which ones
should you do
well
certifications is an important topic
I would say one of the things
I would say that it's very important to
do your certifications
um I wouldn't make that the bee's knees
of where you're going so before I got
into certifications I'd try to get a
broad understanding and learning by
doing and then once you've got a bit of
a handle on that Microsoft in the
certifications
um will often teach you about all the
things to get you certified but they're
also doing a bit of advertising of all
the features so you're learning all that
stuff so certifications are the second
thing the first thing I'd be saying is
Microsoft learned to go through and do
the hands-on experience through through
the Azure instances they give you
levels would overview for lots of things
so you can often do AZ 900 and it'll
give you a really broad view of the sort
of things that are available and then
you can start thinking about
which one yep all right yeah good
suggestion
all right I've been using arm templates
for three years should I be moving to
bicep as a pro I would say as a priority
I'd say it's a very important thing to
do
uh and I know it's work but when you
think about any software that you do you
design software ready for change
the software generally doesn't die
software stays alive while you've got a
budget and while it's useful
and it you like the difference between
you know a beginner developer an
experienced developer is they make it
always ready to change and uh yeah so
that's the same thing infrastructure as
code is very important bicep it makes it
more maintainable so it's a lot easier
to change
any comment on it yeah
yeah that's an excellent tip what's your
name
Randy So Randy gave us uh an excellent
tip um basically there is a converter
um like all converters they're not
perfect but they're useful okay I
generally would start a new project on
bicep and get used to it and then you
know what you're doing rather than going
to an old project and trying to migrate
you know because it's much easier to
migrate when you know what you're meant
to get to
what do you attribute your youthful
appearance to
well
yeah that's a very good question I don't
know
I'd say sitting on the weekend writing
rules has really helped me a lot you
know it's very good for you
yes uh well
um
I hate
um I hate making random decisions
or making decisions and having it lost
and not being able to back it up like
it's it really
sucks when you look at a project and you
know developers leave and change
developers forget things you go onto a
project and you go why are we doing like
this and there's no document I will tell
you that there is a rule on rules to
better on ssw rules that is about do you
have the seven important documents in a
project which describe stuff to the
business to the developers how to get up
and running the F5 experience the
diploma experience Etc
any other substantial questions that
appears
how do I understand all the technical
jargon in the Azure pricing calculator
for example dtus and RSU oh dtus and
rsues well I will tell you uh if you had
have gone to that PDF and just flicked
through and started just learning
broadly about this stuff
all the lingo is there and you pick it
up as you go and then we go to the
pricing calculator you've already seen
all that so it makes sense but I broadly
like I the you know you saw the the
pricing check I know it kind of looked a
bit hairy but it is hairy on the older
stuff but that um those transaction
units
uh are for SQL Server when you're
talking Cosmos they give you this data
transmission unit and the transmission
unit is a blended cost between CPU IO
um
memory like they blend it together and
charge you for that unit basically when
you see that it's generally good because
you're paying what you're using rather
than just paying for a dedicated
instance which you most companies even
big companies don't generally need okay
usage is the better way it's always
cheaper as you saw in the calculator
so it's easy to make it wrong it appears
well what you said to a client that
doesn't want to commit to one year
well what you do is you anchor them at
three years
you tell them can you commit to three
years and they go oh three years
can I I was so much cheaper we can also
get a big discount for one year oh yeah
I'll do one year easy done what's next
oh last question hold on any other
questions guys
all right have a good conference uh and
and tell the NDC organizer thank you for
coming uh from Norway and giving us such
a good uh conference because it's good
to be back and seeing you guys I spoke
at NDC on
um I spoke at NDC Oslo during lockdown I
know clever I sat there
in front of a camera talking and I don't
even know if anyone was watching it was
very sad I sat there I was at midnight I
had to stay up so it hadn't me I had to
do it on Norway friendly time and it was
uh it was a very sad experience this is
awesome I I think uh lockdown has made
me much more grateful to uh you know
hang around with geeks you're all
awesome okay
foreign
[Applause]